Yeah, I saw the thing with your trip, the one where you guys were like dancing naked in the pool.
No, no, you gotta look at the other ones, there's more.
Oh, this light is too good.
I didn't know Campbell wasn't doing much, y'all.
Yeah, he's been there.
Oh yeah, really?
How much have you had to drink, Brendan?
Your pupils are dilated, is it because of the light?
When should we have a sleepover at your house tonight?
We, uh, we played...
We should have a sleepover at, uh...
What's up?
What'd you think of that?
That's pretty crazy.
Dude, uh...
Oh, outro, outro, outro.
Exiles out!
Exiles out.
Do it again, do it again.
Second cut, second cut.
Alright, second cut, second cut.
Cut two, cut two.
What do I say?
Just say, exiles out.
That was sick.
Exiles out!